The first expression would be 2 to the 4th n cubed. I moved the n from the
denominator to the numerator since it has a negative exponent. For this
expression, I move the base of m to the denominator and the base of n to the
numerator. Here, these 2 bases come to the numerator. So aha, I know these two
are equal. This one doesn't match these other expressions, so it's out. For the
second one, the m and the n both move to the numerator with positive exponents,
but the 2 stays in the denominator, because the exponent is a positive 1. This
one would be out, too. For this last one, I have a negative sign in front of the
2. This is not an exponent, so I just list the negative 2 in the denominator.
The n to the negative 3, however, moves up to the numerator because the exponent
is negative. This doesn't match these, so it's out as well. For the last
problem, the two moves up to the numerator because the exponent is negative as
well as the m. This definitely matches the other expressions. So here are the
three. This was a really tricky quiz, so don't worry if you didn't get it right
on the first try. I really wanted you to focus on negative exponents, negative
numbers, and negative exponents for numbers. We have to keep in mind these
differences when working with problems.